just bring you the latest figures from
across the UK so these are the combined
figures for Kobe Guk the government is
saying that a total now of twelve
thousand eight hundred and sixty-eight
patients have died in hospital after
testing positive for corona virus as of
5:00 p.m. yesterday and that is up seven
hundred and sixty-one from twelve
thousand one hundred and seven at the
day before so that is across the whole
of the UK ninety eight thousand just
over ninety eight thousand people have
now so far tested positive for covert
nineteen almost 16,000 of them were
tested yesterday and as of five o'clock
yesterday of as all of those
hospitalized in the UK tested positive
of those twelve thousand eight hundred
and sixty eight in total have sadly died
now of course that doesn't include
people that have died in care homes or
people who have died in a home
environment the latest figures that we
got from national records in Scotland
suggested that around a quarter of the
deaths that have been recorded in
Scotland over the last week were
recorded in care homes so there is a
great concern about the reporting of
those deaths and how they can be linked
to the deaths that we are getting
officially from the government so just
to recap one more time a total of twelve
thousand six hundred near eighty twelve
thousand eight hundred and sixty-eight
patients have died in hospital after
testing positive for coronavirus as of
5:00 p.m. yesterday which is up seven
hundred and sixty one from the day
before